bonjour à tous on va parler de leur
entreprise joy et d'une autre connectés
octopus un peu plus ce qui m'a dit que
swatch octopus watch un truc super
intéressant système ludique mais qui va
nous présenter à l'horizon
donc quand au coût soit chez la première
manche entièrement basé sur des icônes
qui aide les jeunes enfants de 3 à 7 8
ans à apprendre
la notion du temps et à reprendre les
bonnes habitudes ok alors tu peux nous
expliquer un petit peu comment ça marche
comment est ce qu'ils apprennent quel
est le principe
alors cette montre elle donne l'heure
mais sous forme d'icônes elle associe en
fait le temps qui passe à des icônes ça
c'est l'appréhension numéro un très
simple fonction numéro 2 qui je pense
est la plus intéressante c'est que en
tant que parent on a une à plat nos
dispositions qui nous permet de créer
des routines journalières on a plus de
700 icône choisir
représentant diverses étapes de la vie
comme s'habiller tout seul se brosser
les dents aider à débarrasser la table
sortir le chien etc etc etc
le parent va créer des routines
journalières les envoyer sur la montre
la montre est ensuite autonome elle est
équipée d'une mémoire flash
langlois deçà toutes les informations
bluetooth mais ensuite la montre est
autonome on coupe la connexion que tout
de manière à ne pas surexposer les
enfants aux seconds
certains parents qui sont inquiet par
rapport à ça et donc la montée tant
autonome et très légère l'enfant peut
l'apporter à tout moment même à l'école
et donc à différentes étapes de la
journée ou de la semaine la monde se met
à vibrer et afficher certains s'y colle
donc ça qu'ils enfants au bout de trois
à quatre semaines de répétitions
de là même alarme en fait ça devient une
habitude d'accord on peut donc supprimer
cette alarme est passé sur une autre
donc vraiment cette montre l élève à
responsabiliser les enfants
mais également à augmenter la confiance
en lui parce qu'ils sont tous fiers en
fait de pouvoir faire des choses par
eux-mêmes qui répètent 15 x 23 cm dans
la mousse et les dents va procéder dans
les sites à des enfants dont l'un des
deux c'est quelque chose que je pense
tout le monde connaît
donc in fine et ça nous permet nous
parents de passer plus de temps avec nos
enfants jusqu'aux finalement des portes
le sale boulot sur la montre est ce que
tu as là ce témoin j'ai invité 90 est ce
que tu as un truc pour réussir à arrêter
de dire qui piquent à quelque chose
comme ça parce que ça ça me plaît alors
on en est encore pas là
voilà l'intelligence artificielle
viendra total va corriger ça en revanche
on a une
fonctionnalités e
khemissi kheshen donc j'ai pas
communication alors c'est optionnel
parce qu'à certains parents qui veulent
surtout pas récompenser leurs enfants
que ce genre de tâche estime que c'est
un dû c'est la motivation c'est la
motivation mais pour les américains
notamment qui ont bien compris l'intérêt
de ça c'est très sympa en fait l'enfant
que gagner des petites étoiles qui gagne
est dérisoire et ça le motive beaucoup
ok alors l'idée originale elle vient
d'où qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
d'aller sur ce projet là alors c'est un
mélange de plusieurs choses c'est à dire
que moi étant maintenant
et père de deux enfants forcément à
mes projets d'entreprises ont changé
j'avais envie de faire quelque chose qui
aide
les familles en général mais surtout ce
qu'on a découvert c'est que nos enfants
mais également nous les adultes
on est maintenant sur exposé à de très
nombreuses distractions les smartphones
les tablettes et les réseaux sociaux les
emails etc
et ça c'est là ça va pas changer
mais la conséquence et qui en plus de
dix paires activités on arrive de moins
en moins se focaliser sur un truc à ce
que c'est
ici nous allons très appelle ça les dj
attractivité
c'est 11 % des enfants sont atteints ici
c'est comme une maladie en fait alors
qu'en 2003 y en avait que 5 à 6 %
on voit que c'est en train d'augmenter
et pour régler ce problème la soie et
donne des médicaments aux enfants et pas
forcément les maires solution choix en
fait il
son déchet ning seychelles avec les
parents sur comment organiser la vie
finalement prendre des bonnes habitudes
et mettre des routines en place ça c'est
bénéfique
ouais donc nous radio on s'est focalisé
un peu sur ce marché alors en anglais on
appelle ça le billet viol technology ce
couffin milices et tout ce qui va
toucher sur les comportements l'étude
comportementale et c'est ça ça vous
intéresse
donc on a commencé par ce premier
produit
pour les jeunes enfants mais nous on
une roadmap en fait sur les adultes et
teenager's les
sage et cetera
ces suppressions donc on a été accélérée
par axe qui est un accélérateur
américain petit panneau ici et qu'on est
parti
presque cinq mois en chine avec
comarmond associés et là bas on l'a vu
il tirait sur la première version
mais également une housse au challenge
et sur la proposition de valeur parce
qu'au début on est un peu comme
beaucoup start up c'est à dire qu'on
veut mettre plein plein plein de
fonctionnalités et
et nous ont vraiment aidé à me caler sur
vraiment le même sens essentiel est
essentielle
le mossad
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on est arrivé
sur iphone vs watch n'a qu'en partie
voilà gentil mais c'est que c'est un
produit qui est vraiment sur le marché
américain premier oui j'en ai tout alors
j'ai basé à san francisco tooway on est
passé à sa prose est donc la société a
été créée en 2016 2016 a été passé à la
r&d
r&d qu'on avait notre premier prototype
on a décidé d'essayer d'avoir une preuve
de trop de marques extraction pour qu'on
la fait une campagne kickstarter aux
états unis pourtant
dans le monde mais essentiellement aux
états unis donc ça s'est bien passé on a
fait presque 800 mille dollars et
ensuite on est passé sur une digue au bo
et c'est seulement là qu'on a dit on va
là on est sur quelque chose où va le
commercialiser donc voilà ça c'était
l'année 2016 et l'année a permis de vous
rendre compte qu'ils avaient un besoin
qui avait une envie on gagne de public
exactement ça nous a aussi été à prendre
du fipac et donc même à modifier en fait
le prototype avant de le commercialiser
et en 2017 on a
livrés à nos packs heures les premières
unités et surtout et ça c'est énorme on
a pu signer un deal avec un des plus
grands
retailer des états unis qui est target
c'est un peu comme carrefour et donc on
a été enfin on est toujours distribué
dans 1500 magasins target
on a commencé en août sur l'année
dernière
donc ça c'était vraiment
et maintenant les super fier d'être en
france depuis noël chez oxybul éveil et
jeux
ok cool l'enseignement pour vous trouver
à quel prix enfin le marché français
marché français elle est un peu trop
cher pour l'instant non il a 79 dollars
sur le marché américain ok et là en
france elle à 99 euros
mais on va faire baisser ce prix
d'accord c'est la bonne résolution
jamais des actes au hockey génial bon
bah écoute merci beaucoup à ce que tu
fais d'autres choses à rajouter france
merci merci pour l'opportunité
merci beaucoup je vous invite à me
laisser des commentaires je sais pas si
vous êtes parent et que cette solution
pourrait vous intéresser pour vos
enfants vous invite bien évidemment à me
laisser des commentaires des jolies
pouces vous marquez tout ça restez
connectés abonnez-vous parce qu'on va
parler encore et toujours plus
d'entreprises françaises innovantes
merci beaucoup merci à bientôt à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]